so it's another day and another
embarrassing failure for the Trump
administration this time it's Donald
Trump's nominee to replace his former
Secretary of Defense Jim mattis who has
bailed out and wants no part of working
for the Trump administration Donald
Trump had nominated a guy named Patrick
Shanahan to fill the position and
Shanahan had been the acting secretary
of defense since Jim mattis left because
he wanted no part of the Trump
administration and before I go any
further this is a serious position I
mean I don't think I should have to say
this but this is a position that should
be filled and filled with a responsible
competent qualified adult and Shanahan
has announced that he is resigning as
allegations that he punched his ex-wife
in the stomach have extended an FBI
background check into Shanahan Shanahan
has denied punching his wife in the
stomach says his wife actually is the
one who started the fight and ultimately
his wife is the one who was arrested and
charged with domestic violence and this
entire incident overlaps whether is
connected to a fight that supposedly
started because of a briefcase the
contents of which Shanahan would keep in
a closet near their bathroom we don't
need to go into all of the details but
this is off-the-wall bonkers family
drama and in general Shanahan's family
life is a pretty big mess his son when
17 years old hit his mother with a
baseball bat she was in the hospital
because of it Shanahan flew from Seattle
to Florida and stayed at a hotel with
his son until his son eventually turned
himself in I mean it's truly horrible
stuff a lot of different views as to
what is the exact truth about this but
ultimately this has led to Shanahan
resigning and Donald Trump following up
by withdrawing Shanahan's nomination and
once again this gets back to the same
issue that has been plaguing the Trump
administration if the Trump
administration took background checks
more seriously and did their own
so-called extreme vetting before the FBI
gets into all of this it would save
everyone a lot of public embarrassment
it would save the Trump administration
a lot of wasted time in nominating and
then withdrawing nominations for people
who are entangled in all sorts of
personal messes so this is one of those
cases though where Trump's embarrassment
and failure to get his top pick into a
position might actually result in
getting somebody even worse on the job
Donald Trump has now named mark Esper
the Secretary of the army to be acting
Secretary of Defense we don't know
whether he will be Trump's eventual
nominee for permanent Secretary of
Defense but what we do know is that
Esper is a total military-industrial
complex guy he's a former executive at
Raytheon one of the biggest contractors
of defense contractors in the country
although it's not like Shanahan wasn't
connected to the military-industrial
complex maybe slightly less ominously
Shanahan worked for Boeing for 30 years
but for me this story is a reminder yes
of trumps constant failures that are
plaguing his administration but also of
the fact that our government is just
riddled with every kind of corporate
raider and plutocrat and kleptocrat and
corporatist and the like and we just
don't have nearly enough of the right
types of people representing us and
acting on our behalf we don't even know
at this point as I said whether Mark
Esper will eventually be Trump's pick
for permanent secretary of defense he's
just now acting secretary of defense and
once again the whole process starts over
again but the bottom line here is number
one we have way too many of these
military-industrial complex corporate
raider types involved in government in
the same way that we have too many
lobbyists involved and we have too many
lawyers involved and we should have
wider representation although I
understand Secretary of Defense you
don't necessarily want a schoolteacher
although how bad could it get right I
mean I would almost consider whether a
schoolteacher could do as good of a job
as some of the people that are put in
there but you have to understand that
Donald Trump is if you believe he's
draining the swamp he's filling it with
even worse garbage they're removing
recyclable garbage from the swamp and
putting in the stuff that won't
decompose for a thousand a thousand
years but but by
in the back of all of this is there the
possibility that the real reason for the
change in who is going to be Donald from
Secretary of Defense could be related to
Iran policy is it possible that as
Tucker Carlson is advising Trump on Iran
now I'll get to that story later in the
show is it possible that Trump and
Shanahan did not see eye-to-eye on what
Iran policy should be I don't know but
the real sort of true red alert here
remains which is we still don't have a
permanent Secretary of Defense the last
time this happened I believe was George
HW Bush's administration not George W
Bush George HW Bush before Bill Clinton
when there was an Acting Secretary of
Defense for around a couple of months I
believe and no permanent one if I'm
wrong on that I'm sure people are going
to write in and let me know